JONATHAN KARMEL:
In a few minutes,
I'll invite
Alasdair, PD manager.
And together, we're going to
talk about the update to Google
Play Instant since we
launched Instant games at I/O
just five months ago.
I'll then invite An from
Small Giant Games onto stage.
And she'll talk about
her experience developing
an Instant game.
So Google Play Instant--
the idea was to really
improve the user experience,
and then directly
have a positive impact
on developers' businesses.
And let's start
with the user side.
So what is the user experience?
Well, you click on a URL
or you click on Try Now,
and you dive into a
native experience.
And this allows you
to understand the game
before you install.
And it also gives opportunities
for new discovery experiences
beyond the Play Store
And we believe this is
transformative to discovery.
Because playing games is the
right way to evaluate games.
I don't think you've ever
heard of someone saying,
you have to play this game,
their app icon is amazing.
You say, you have
to play this game.
I played it myself.
And it's awesome.
And that's basically
how you do discovery.
You play the game.
And then you
determine, do I want
to spend hours and hours playing
this game into the future?
This is the exact way
you should discover.
And we believe this is the right
evolution of the Play Store.
So back in the day, you
had the Android Market.
And you got a few beautiful
icons to assess and install.
Then we evolved.
And we said, OK,
what if we brought
some of the strength of
Google to the Play Store?
Personal recommendations,
better search,
a way for us to go deeper
into the catalog as a user
and discover more and more of
what is possible on Android.
And more recently, we
launched the Play Games app,
which was our first foray into
content-first experiences,
where you saw preroll
videos and starting
to see the content that
you'll get once you install.
But the future of
the Play Store is
where it is purely
content-first,
where you get to play the
game first, and then install.
And that is the future.
And that is what
Google Play Instant
provides the Play Store.
And we're really excited about
this, because this is not
a new playbook.
There's been precedents
set in the media.
Every time that media becomes
instant, consumption goes up--
both the depth of consumption
as well as the breadth.
We've seen it with music.
We've seen it with books.
We've seen it with movies.
We've also seen it with search.
As we decrease
latency, usage goes up.
And we think that's an
incredible thing for users,
because they get to experience
more, but also for developers
and what is possible
to bring to users.
So that's the user side.
Let's now talk about
you, the developers.
What is in it for you?
Well, with Google
Play Instant, we're
seeing better users coming
through your pipeline.
We're seeing more installs.
And we're seeing
more opportunities
to bring your game onto
different surfaces, not just
the Play Store.
When you have a URL
link, you can bring it
to many different surfaces.
And the developer
community, you,
are responding extremely well.
We've just been live
for five months.
And this is just a small
number of the game developers
who have adopted in that
short period of time.
And what we believe is possible
with Google Play Instant
is an extension of the
whole developer lifecycle.
It doesn't matter where
you are for a specific game
on this lifecycle.
If you're a new game that
hasn't even launched,
use preregistration
and use Try Now
to drive that new usage
even ahead of launching.
Or it will decrease your
feature development cost
by trying out new
features in Try Now
and, before you incorporate
it into your installed game,
testing it out and seeing
if your audience is going
to respond favorably to it.
Or if maybe you're in the
middle, one of your games
has launched and now you're
just trying to get more users,
you're trying to
augment your user base--
so this is a mechanism
to reach new users
that you might have not been
able to reach in the past
because they were fearful
of that install friction.
Or you have a mature game.
And now, you're
thinking about, how
do I bring back some of
those churned users, people
who have uninstalled?
What type of experience
can I provide them
that is a new
feature, a new level,
something they haven't
experienced yet
and it'll bring them
back to your game?
One thing that we have
emphasized from the get-go
is that we might be
a new platform trying
to drive new discovery, but
we want the developer tooling
to be identical to
what you have and used
in the past for Android games.
So it's the same game
engines that you've
used, the same tool chain.
Everything is the same.
And we've worked really
hard to make sure
that convergence happens.
And what that means
is that any game
that's live as an Android game
can become an Instant game.
We've seen it with our
top grossing games.
We've seen it with AR games.
We've seen it with some
of our large games.
So if you're 350 [? megs, ?]
if you're one gig,
there is a path for you
to become an Instant game.
And we've seen it with
resource-strapped indie
developers have found ways to
launch through Instant games.
And we'll get more
and more and more
into that in the coming slides.
With that, I want to
invite Alasdair up.
He's going to talk about how
you can get even more uplift
and how we have figured out
ways to decrease the developer
costs as well.
ALASDAIR MCMASTER:
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
So as you've seen,
Instant games is
designed to be an integral part
of all aspects of your game
design.
So any part of
the lifecycle, you
can have an Instant
game made for it.
So now, you can expect
to have bigger launches
by reaching more users even
easier before you actually
bring your game to the store.
And then as you've
seen, when you already
have an existing title
in your portfolio,
why not bring some more virality
to it with an Instant game.
But I think what's also
important to discuss now
is surfacing and how we
can do that in the store
and how there's different
areas for you, the developer,
to show your Instant game.
So some of you
here today, you're
already going to be
looking at Instant games.
And hopefully, all
of you are going
to be looking into it by the
end of this presentation.
But I think it's important
that you should understand
from the get-go that the
Try Now button is really
only scratching the surface of
what the opportunity here is.
There's various placements and
collections in the Play Store.
And then of course, there's
the all important store listing
page, where you can work
to really drive conversions
on your page by having users try
your game before they download
it.
Then there's the Play Games
Arcade in the Play Games app.
And this is a brand
new surface where
you're able to showcase
your Instant game
and allow users to try it.
And then, of course,
there's the old adage
of social linking and virality.
Why not have the
option of letting
your users share
invites and invitations
to clans, for example, with
their friends and family?
And I think what's really
interesting is that we've
been working very
hard to expand Instant
games into new areas such as
premium and preregistration.
As some of you here will
know, the premium games
was previously just a
screenshot and a video
on your store listing page.
But now, we're very
proud to say that you
have the option of adding
an Instant game to this.
And what's super important
and very exciting here
is this can really increase
your store conversion rate,
as you're giving the
user the opportunity
to try the game before
they actually commit
to purchasing it.
And I think that that's
really important,
as this lowers the crucial
entry barrier to your title
and also gives you, the
developer, a real platform
to showcase your premium games.
And we've also worked
hard on top of that
to bring some prelaunch
opportunities to Instant games.
And what's really
exciting about this
is that you're able to create
virality around your game
by adding it to
your preregistration
before you've even
launched your game.
So why wouldn't
you take advantage
of this when you have the
opportunity to drive sign-ups
by creating virality
and really giving
a first taste and a
sneak peek of your game
before it's even in the store?
And I think this is going to be
really integral going forward
when you want to
have a big launch
and really create excitement
and hype about your titles.
And I think looking forward--
this is also very important
is that coming this quarter
we have the ambition
to launch the Games Room
in the Play Games app.
And this is really exciting,
as this will give users
a similar experience
to what they
know before with
something-- browsing
YouTube videos for instance, but
obviously with Instant games.
So this will be an
immersive experience.
And it will allow the users
to seamlessly switch from game
to game in the Games
Room not compromising
on the game quality or the
user experience at all.
And you may be wondering
how we managed to do that.
So as we roll this out, you
will see the Instant games--
funnily enough given the
instant in its title--
is actually how it
moves from game to game.
And we're proud to say that this
is due to a new feature that
allows us to preload the
subsequent games coming,
creating a seamless
experience and making sure
that you, the
developer, don't have
to compromise on the Instant
game and the instant experience
that you've worked
so hard to create.
So I think we can both
agree now that Instant games
and the opportunities it
offers is pretty incredible.
And there's a variety
of applications
that you can do with
your instant games now.
And this is only growing.
And we're working
hard to make it
even easier for you to
develop these games in-house.
So if you can cast your mind
back a little while to I/O,
you may remember that we
announced the Unity Beta
program.
And that the Unity plugin
was available on GitHub.
Well, today, any Unity
developer can easily
create an Instant game and
implement it on our store.
And we're very happy to
say that the plugin is
available in the
Unity Asset Store.
And given the ease
of this development,
we're seeing significant
adoption from Unity developers
with roughly 50% of the
newly published Instant
games being Unity-based.
And this is a similar
story for Cocos2d.
At I/O, we announced
the alpha version.
And today, this
is fully launched.
And the IDE experience
for Cocos Instant games
is phenomenal with the
drag and select feature.
And given the fact that
Cocos is used by around 20%
of developers, this
really is great news.
So you've seen our commitment
to developing and innovating
instant games and making it
easier for you, the developer,
to develop your own games.
But we believe that this is
an incredible opportunity that
should be open to
every single developer
regardless of size,
engineering capacity, or even
your technical ability.
So I've shown you ways
that you, as a developer,
using your own
current tooling are
able to easily launch and
implement your own Instant
games.
However, some of
you simply might not
have the resources to
commit to development today.
And you're not alone.
We've heard this from
a lot of developers.
Fortunately, we're
seeing growing ecosystem
of agencies, such as the ones
here, who you can work with
to develop an Instant game.
So if you don't have the
development resources,
you don't have to worry.
You're not going to miss out.
You can work with these agencies
to develop your own Instant
game.
And what's exciting here
is that agencies like this
are user acquisition
and attribution experts.
So they really know
what they're doing.
And they know how to drive
installs to your titles.
Jam City is just one
example of many developers
if you've seen that
are utilizing agencies
like this in order to create
a unique instant experience.
As we go forward, Google Play--
we're going to work as hard as
we can to implement and invest
more in our game engines
and work harder to make sure
that we can really push forward
the discovery of your Instant
games on the Play Store.
We're going to work
incredibly hard to make sure
that we give you the best
opportunity to innovate
on this amazing technology.
And we really are super
excited to see where
you're going to take this next.
Now, I'm going to pass you
back to Jonathan, who's
going to take you through
some of the impact the Instant
games can have for you in
a little bit more detail.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN KARMEL: So, whoa--
hello.
I get to come back
on stage just to talk
about our successes, which is
great, and talk about numbers.
So let's dive into that.
If you look at the top grossing
game developers, 50% of them
have already launched
an Instant game.
So as I mentioned earlier on,
adoption has really taken off.
And we're really excited to
see these numbers, again,
in just five months
of being live.
And then if you look
at just this week--
so I just had to create this
slide, because I didn't even
realize it until last night,
that all these games just
started launching
just this week.
So additional game
developers that have launched
includes Sega, Outfit 7, and
NC Soft, InnoGames, and Double
Down.
So we're really
excited just to see
that we believe we're at this
inflection point right now.
I think App On Board alone
launched eight games this week.
So we're really excited to
see all the adoption that's
happening for Instant games.
And I just took you through
the different life cycles
and how you can take advantage
of Instant games at each point.
And we've already seen
this done by Scopely.
Scopely has basically converted
their portfolio of games
into Instant games.
So if you see for
preregistrations,
they used "Looney Tunes Mayhem"
to use it for preregistrations
before they even launched.
And then for games that are
just in the growth phase,
like "Wheel of Fortune"
and "Walking Dead,"
they wanted to
augment the user base.
So they focused on Try Now
and driving that virality.
And then for their
more mature games,
like Yahtzee, they
decided that they
were going to try to bring
back churn users by showing
an experience that really
excites the user who
might have uninstalled it to get
back into installing "Yahtzee."
For the preregistration--
this is our first example
of using Try Now
for preregistration.
And we already drove
20% of the installs--
sorry, 20% of the
preregistrations
were from Instant games.
And the conversion, once you've
landed in an Instant game,
was 53% to preregistration.
And this is a baseline.
We haven't even optimized
these numbers yet.
So we're really
excited to see this.
And as we tune this, we
expect the 53% number
to increase significantly.
But we also expect
that, as users
start understanding
what Try Now means
and what the experience
is going to be,
you'll start seeing
click-through rates increasing
such that 20% can
increase as well.
Now, we're also seeing
better users coming out
the other end of Instant games.
So for Jam City,
"Cookie Jam Blast,"
they saw a 32% increase
in day seven retention
for users who
installed after playing
the Instant game versus just the
normal organic installations.
And what about monetization?
Well, Playtika's "House
of Fun" saw a 48% increase
in revenue per
install if the user
had come through an
Instant game versus if they
came through an
organic installation.
And for the indie
developers in the audience,
I think this is a
huge value proposition
for an indie developer.
You've focused on
a quality game.
But you might not have
the same brand recognition
or same marketing dollars as
some other game developers.
So usually, what happens
when a user clicks Try Now
for an indie game
developer, or an indie game,
is they're pleasantly surprised,
because you've invested
in that quality of game.
So they click on it.
And they end up
installing at a high rate.
We've seen this with "Gungun"
having a 20% increase in user
acquisition, "Jungle Adventures
2" having an almost 9% increase
in user acquisition,
and "Bubble Shoot
Pet" having an 8% increase
in user acquisition.
Well, I obviously am excited
about Google Play Instant,
because I'm the
product manager for it.
But I really think
that you would
benefit by hearing about how
a game developer has actually
used Instant games
and developed for it.
So I'd like to invite An
Vu from Small Giant Games
to talk about her experience
with Google Play Instant.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AN VU: Thank you.
Hello, hi, I'm An.
I'm the director of performance
marketing at Small Giant Games.
We are a company
based in Finland
and have launched
three games, including
"Empires and Puzzles," a
top 10 grossing game in 100
countries including the US.
We also won the Best
Breakthrough Hit Award
by Google Play
earlier this year.
So today, I'm going
to talk to you
about how we use data to
build our Instant Game,
what worked for us
and what didn't,
and some recommendations
going forward.
Organic conversion benchmark
for the average RPG game
is at 8% on Google Play.
That means that over 90% of
users who land at the app page
do not download.
And we know that through
continuous AB testing
that App Store
optimization can only
move the needle a little bit.
Optimizing the App
Store conversion
is especially crucial when
running high budget UA
campaigns.
70% of our UA budget goes
towards driving traffic
to the Google Play
Store, so that we
knew that we had to optimize
the store conversion
rate beyond just ASO testing.
The user acquisition funnel
has a lot of friction
at every step of the way.
But bridging the gap
between decision and action
was really key for us in
optimizing user acquisition.
When we introduced playable
ads compared to video ads,
we saw 170% more installs.
And we saw that the
click-to-install rate improved
by 38%, thus increasing the
overall efficiency of our UA
campaigns by 25%.
Encouraged by our
results, we were
encouraged to take
this experience
and try to scale it
as much as possible.
How can we get as many users
to be hooked to this game
in under a minute as possible?
And this was around the
time that Google Play
introduced Instant games.
We saw the opportunity when they
introduced the Unity plug-in.
So we decided to
make the Instant
game available to all users.
The question was how to distill
this multifaceted game of base
building, hero collecting,
match-three, and PVP
into a single,
memorable experience.
That's when we used
our performance data
to collect our experience
to build an Instant game.
We partner with the
external developer called
Seepia Games to build what
we want to be a streamlined,
optimized but fun
Instant game experience.
In analyzing the data, we
took away some key learnings.
First of all, don't cut corners.
In this first
example here, we saw
that having a
non-optimized tutorial
does not convert
users very well,
because it left users feeling
confused and frustrated on not
knowing how to play the game.
We solved this problem later on
by scaling down the game board
so that it's easier.
But that didn't work
out well either,
because the players
dismissed that
as being too simple
and too basic.
And then the final
step was getting
the right mix of an
immersive experience
that's complex enough to
hold the user's attention
as well as streamlined enough
to play without a long tutorial.
We also tested to see the
visual appeal of the game.
We found out that
the players prefer
battling a dragon
over a random shark
with knives walking
on the beach.
So getting the
visual appeal of it
was just as important as
getting the mechanics right.
We tested many different
levels and bosses.
And we found that experimenting
with the difficulty
rate or the win rate was
very important in getting
the users to convert.
Our hypothesis was
that, if a user loses,
he'll be more likely to download
the game and try to beat it.
So we create two versions
of every single level.
We've made a hard
one and an easy one.
And surprisingly,
the easy one was
more effective in converting
users to download.
Building on the
complexity of the game,
we wanted to create a meta
game for the experience.
So we moved away from
a randomized sequence
to a more coherent saga map
much like the real game.
And this experience here
saves your progress.
So if you play two levels and
then you don't install it,
the next time that you
interact with the Instant game,
it will take you to the
boss at level three.
Overall, we experimented with
over 30 different versions
to find the right complexity,
length, difficulty,
and visual appeal of the game.
So if you want to
get started, I would
recommend finding
a developer who's
experienced in game design and
who has the technical know-how
to build many different
ideas and concepts
and iterate on those
ideas to collect data.
Using that data, then you
can find the right length,
complexity, visual appeal, and
difficulty to build your game.
You don't want to cut
corners, because you
want to instantly wow the users
with the first time experience.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]